los incendios en la selva amazónica de
brasil se intensifican este miércoles
datos gubernamentales revelaron que en
agosto la zona sufre la ola de incendios
más grande en más de una década el
instituto nacional de investigaciones
espaciales de brasil registró más de 31
mil alertas de incendios en la amazonía
en los primeros 30 días del mes
desde 2019 principalmente se nota que
utiliza el fuego para limpiar estas
áreas y como este escenario de sequía es
bastante acentuado este fuego se propaga
rápidamente y hace que un número de
incendios detectados y el área afectada
por los incendios sea muy alto
este aumento se registra en medio de la
campaña presidencial y con los
principales candidatos en posturas
diametralmente opuestas sobre cómo
enfrentar la destrucción de la selva
amazónica rodeado de líderes indígenas
locales el ex presidente lula de silva
dijo este miércoles que si es elegido
impulsará acuerdos mundiales para
enfrentar el calentamiento global
es necesario que haya responsabilidades
y tiene que haber gobiernos mundiales
más fuertes unas naciones unidas- más
fuertes en las que los países participen
con verdadero poder de decisión
principalmente en el tema climático si
no seguimos dando discursos sin
pronunciar
expertos señalan a las políticas de
bolsonaro como las responsables de
debilitar los esfuerzos por proteger el
llamado pulmón del mundo